première édition de la fête de la
jeunesse à poissy l'occasion pour la
ville de célébrer de jeunes talents et
de faire découvrir de nouveaux sports
tels que le technopôle ou encore le bmx
flatland la particularité c'est de faire
des figures sur un sol plat
le but ne pas poser le pied par terre et
d'être le plus créatif possible voilà le
plus important c'est d'être original et
inventer ses propres figures c'était un
bon moyen de faire une petite démo
petite initiation aussi pour les jeunes
delà de la ville surtout qu'il ya un
gros skate parc à côté très bien ce soir
mais on connaît moins bien lotis mans le
milieu du e street rider du bmx et c'est
vrai que vision du vélo les deux roues
c'est quelque chose qui est complètement
nouveau et je pense qu'il ya encore
beaucoup de choses à faire et tendre sur
ce score là ce samedi 4 juin le célèbre
youtuber football devine sky aux
centaines de millions de vues sur
internet avait également fait le
déplacement
une opportunité pour lui de faire
découvrir sa pratique qui a également
rencontré ses abonnés franchement c'est
une réussite il ya beaucoup de gens qui
sont venus est bon il faisait beau il a
commencé à pleuvoir pendant que je fais
à l'interview mais alors franchement
c'est top il ya voilà y'a du petit pont
il ya du une cible géante rien peu de
tout y est même du vélo du bmx donc
franchement c'est une grande réussite
pour moi en tout cas j'ai vraiment
apprécié avec près de 2000 visiteurs
cette fête de la jeunesse est considérée
comme un succès une nouvelle édition est
prévue l'année prochaine
[Musique]